[Music]
transformers are back with one of the
biggest movies of the Christmas holidays
the bumblebee film has some nice plot
progression for the universe and
throughout this video I'll be breaking
down everything that you need to know
about the film and its ending there will
be heavy spoilers so if you're yet to
see the movie then I highly suggest that
you turn off now there's a lot in there
for fans of the franchise for everyone
else and definition and welcome to the
channel where I roon it so you don't
have to we open on the war for Cybertron
with the Autobots facing off against the
Decepticons is much brighter approach to
the character design immediately had me
and I loved seeing Soundwave in his
actual 80s look during the conflict
Optimus Prime decides that the Autobots
must leave the planet to find refuge
from the wall Optimus stays behind and
tasks b12 seven aka bumblebee with
heading to earth to find solitude
stating that they will all reunite soon
we then join agent burns played by John
Cena
who witnesses bumblebee crash-land on
the planet during a training exercise
that images many offices burns comes
face to face with one will be who was
then ambushed by blitz wing disguised as
a jet blitz wing and the rest of the
Decepticons are trying to find out
whether your buttery grouping and he
battles it out with the character and
rips out bumblebees voice box in an
awesome exchange the counter attacks
this by pulling some missiles from
blitzwing's armor which blows him up
however bee is heavily damaged in the
process and falls down a mountain thus
losing his memory core and had the key
functions he winds up near some people
and turns himself into a course who can
shut down and hide in safety we are then
introduced to Charlie who's a typical
eighties tomboy due to her father
passing away she feels alienated from
her family
Charlie spends most of her spare time
working on the car here in a dad owned
before his heart attack and this keeps
her mind occupied she works out her
Uncle Frank's scrapyard which is where
she discovers the yellow bo that
bumblebee is currently disguised as
after turning the car on emits a signal
which goes into space we travel
interstellar to see that the Decepticons
have cornered Cliffjumper
as he refuses to talk they
and then pick upon be signal which leads
their day we returned to Charlie telling
her mum that she really wants a car for
a birthday which just so happens to be
the next day the mother states that she
can't afford it and this causes Charlie
to go to Frank's whether to make a deal
that if Charlie can fix the beetle she
can keep it be is so dirty he actually
has one under his bonnet to excuse the
pun but Charlie doesn't care and begins
working on him
shatter and dropkick land on earth and
meet with burns in the Army as Burns is
still burnt excuse the punch from the
first encounter
he's very distrusting the decepticons
convinced him that they are tracking
criminals from their home and are given
access to telephones satellites and more
we cut back to Charlie working on B in
her garage where she discovers his true
nature
Charlie names him bumblebee but not
because of the bees under his bonnet or
even his colour but because of the
buzzing type of noise that he makes when
he can't talk due to his voice box
missing charlie fixes his voice using
radio similar to the first film be
slowly adjust to earth as Charlie begins
dating a boy she has a crush on be left
alone accidentally trashes the house and
triggers an Energon charge that alerts
the decepticon scanners and both
Decepticons track down the source by
this point the Decepticon septic aliy
made the internet for Humanity and was
agent burns doesn't agree with their
actions he realizes that he may finally
be able to get revenge on bumblebee with
their help he in the army track beat
down and stopped Charlie her boy and B
with a roadblock
Charlie insists that B doesn't fight
back to show that he isn't dangerous but
the army take him down with high-voltage
guns which electrifies Charlie when she
attempts to save him she is knocked out
by the charge and wakes up in a trashed
house to a very confused mother
Charlie explains that since losing her
father she's been very lonely but her
mother is enraged by this and screams
that she doesn't get to make a
replacement for a father just because
he's gone it's a really touching moment
that shows just how damaged both her and
a mother are by the loss and it's
something that will definitely stick
with viewers eventually her mother does
the right thing and creates a diversion
between Charlie and the army which
allows the girl to go on
skooby a friend Charlie discovers be
being tortured by the Decepticons and
they find the message from Optimus which
reveals that they are meeting on earth
the Decepticons rushed to a radio tower
to signal that kind to come to earth and
wipe out the planet they kill B and the
scientist who overhears the plot charlie
manages to revive be using a
high-voltage gun from earlier which
brings him back to life B takes down one
of the Decepticons whilst Charlie climbs
the tower to disable it in the battle at
B safes burns from a crashing helicopter
and burns finally realizes that he's
been fighting for the wrong side the
area becomes flooded during the fight
and B defeats the remaining Decepticon
being Charlie flee the area with burns
distracting the army in order to buy
them more time BB and Charlie arrive at
the Golden Gate Bridge and the two
decide to part ways as B has bigger
things that Charlie cannot hold him back
from we see B change into a better car
and drive over the bridge eagle-eyed
viewers will notice that a truck drives
alongside him that looks exactly like
Optimus Prime and it's clear that the
two were reunited when they exchanged
words at the end optimus thanks b 1 to 7
for all the hard work which is when
bumblebee who's finally mastered his
voice box states that he's not B 1 to 7
he's bumblebee the other Autobots land
on earth and we watch as Charlie finally
fixes the car the hair and a father were
working on all along ultimately this
film to me is about separation and the
rebuilding of relationships both B and
Charlie go through a process of losing
something they love finding stability on
their own and then realizing that the
state of solitude ultimately makes them
weak it's a neat little subtext that
showcases that at the core of this film
is a message of friendship and family
that really elevates it above the rest
of the series so what are your thoughts
on bumblebee did you enjoy the film and
what you hope to see with the franchise
going forward comment below and let me
know and if you enjoyed this video then
please like it and check out my review
of the film which will be linked at the
end of this video this is a channel for
people who are mad into movies so if
that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this I've been definition
you've been the best and I'll see you
next time take care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]